on termine avec le cinéma une petite
merveille venus du japon un film
d'animation
récompensé par l'ours d'or du festival
de berlin
son réalisateur hayao miyazaki avait
déjà conquis le public français avec la
princesse mononoké cette fois son film
s'appelle le voyage de chihiro marie-jo
jours une fillette de 10 ans plongée
dans un univers parallèle
personne ne doit venir et il tenir
j'entends vite avant que la nuit tombe
celui d'un établissement thermal pour
divinité esprits en vacances où l'on
transforme les humains en cochon et si
les humains n'ont jamais été les
bienvenues monde étrange et instructive
comme les convictions de myazaki
géomètre en dessin animé derniers
résistants entre les mangas et autres
produits à la chaîne japonais ces
studios s'appelle ghibli d'une honda
vent qui balaye tout sur son passage
il reste un artisan dessin par des
saints à l'ancien fidèle à ses
collaborateurs comme aux traditions
ces personnages existent il y a toujours
un modèle quelque part quant aux dieux
je suis persuadé qu'il y en a partout
par exemple sur cette table sur le toit
moi j'essaie dans mon film de leur
donner des formes
tout est ici pensé travailler la forme
comme le font un monde fantastique
certes mais un discours réaliste
l'écologie cheval de bataille jamais
qu'une heure
notre la force de la parole la confiance
en soi autant de double lecture et le
travail quartier heroes doit se faire
embaucher pour survivre dans ce sauna un
sont ces femmes qui pourrait peut-être
faire l'effort l'ine scène vous venez
d'être promu au grand mois les grenats
le travail s'est pas seulement pour
gagner sa vie
c'est une façon de s'inscrire dans le
monde de se rencontrer et de découvrir
l'autre c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire
zéro une petite alice un peu paumé
passer derrière le miroir pour retrouver
son identité dans un monde
merveilleusement réel deux heures
d'enchantement
même si on n'est plus un enfant